okay I thought come in and sit down
because you watched the documentary
Netflix announces on last week or
something what you sit here not yet
Netflix announces yeah yeah hold for the
queue Netflix announces that they're
doing a documentary on fire fest which
was that that big music festival that
was a disaster in the in an island in
the Bahamas
yeah promise first-class treatment and
all these amazing for like VIP tents
what I'm sorry my son I'm sorry no that
will operate a little operate around
that part yeah we'll see if we can make
up for that so you know this group
called [ __ ] Jerry which is a marketing
group they're the ones who produced this
documentary and they produced it for
Netflix now Netflix wanted to get the
guy who organized the whole festival the
guy who's in charge of fire but they
didn't get him because he said that he's
charging he wants to get paid to be in
these documentaries no we're not paying
you to be in this but how much does he
want I don't know but they didn't pay
him for it they said we're gonna put
this out and they said it's coming out
what days they come out Friday is that
right four days from now Friday so
yesterday Hulu comes out and says look a
lot of the stuff that [ __ ] Jerry is
saying is very very biased because they
were involved in the marketing of the
thing they're gonna make themselves look
good so we're doing our own fire fest
documentary we have the guy who
organized fire fest in the documentary
and Netflix is like oh that's kind of
[ __ ] up and Hulu is like wait you
haven't heard anything yet because we're
actually putting it out right now
no no nothing right it came out
yesterday it was just available
completely makes the [ __ ] Jerry group
look terrible makes the guy who
organized it look terrible makes I mean
ja Rule look Wow a rule what is he look
bad
yeah they pull the under cutters they
pulled the under under cutters formula
did you like it I love it you didn't see
it for free somewhere else not just Hulu
yeah you could see it i'm i think
billboards streaming you know you said
the hollywood so you haven't seen it
don't see that publicly again
y'know knows a hot dog is I know
okay so then before we do that then I
don't want to talk about right instead
let's bring Angie in would just bring
Angie in who works here at serious she's
a big yeah bring Angie in I don't see no
chip yeah go on the other side of Jim
because I feel like there should be a
buffer well well played yeah just you
know in case there's any Angie works
here at Sirius XM and we've kind of over
the last year or so probably a little
more at this point it's been really kind
of pathetically long more than a year it
has been more yeah sure okay I wanted to
give him the benefit of the doubt this
year yeah we've been talking to hotdogs
about how he was deeply in love not get
to the bottom of all of it he's deeply
in love with this girl that he hangs out
with their friends and at first we were
wondering like oh maybe there's
something going on here and then more
recently and I really mean within the
last like eight to nine months it became
clear that hot dog had been viciously
friend-zoned and that while he was still
madly in love with this woman she had
made it very very clear that they were
buds well women can do that a lot easier
than we can't women can know you like
them and be comfortable being your
friend and they don't want to confront
it or address it because they know man
it's a little harder for us to do that I
think women women deal with it more than
we do like the guy who likes them so we
think that he likes and it's been it's
beneficial to have an emotional friend
sure you know to have a friend who's
there for emotional support and things
like that but the reason I bring all
that up is because you know ironically
enough Angie is that girl she is and now
they're both here in that [ __ ] he had
fun are you pointing at me like that
I did nothing wrong you're pointing at
me all right I did something wrong I'm
just pointing I do I hate it when your
point you know talked about this like
hello
you talked about it when did he point
what did you say about his point I think
points in my face I told to stop
pointing in my face and he's doing it
now what is he pointing it's good there
is a buffer not in your face he's
pointing down no well say any points I
don't know just if I'm being annoying
he's like stop it something like that
I'm picking up already number one
relationship bickering relationship
bickering and number two hot dogs voice
has already gone up six octaves voice
always does that also he made me wait in
a restaurant by myself for half an hour
on Saturday night what is that to do
with it you sent him home on a train so
you could stop it
you know stopping it there I found a
friend on the street who's divorced I
was eight I got there like at 8:10 you
know we need where we're waiting here
we're already off off the ranch hold on
when you guys were in Long Island and he
was going to take the train back with
you and you were gonna take the train
with it at what point did you decide you
working and meet the hot dog on the
train here's what happened right so hot
dog and Angie are hanging out we're
going there for the chip show right yeah
I can tear to do this on the air because
we're not gonna talk about anything else
we're not gonna talk about let me
explain okay we were it was the chip
chip person live show I said hot dog you
know chip is looking for a girl for the
show not floozy I said floozies I
thought hot dog was gonna bring one of
his floozy sure and instead stripper he
brought the love of his life his partner
and so Angie came she did a great job by
the way she did the dating game that was
all fun they had agreed to take the
train back together yes and after the
show hot dog was kind of cleaning up
Angie ditched him went and did something
else don't know no no we don't know what
you did
when did something else found somebody
else in Long Island to hang I said I'll
meet you at the train station right and
I know this began wrecked that was bad I
actually gave hott Dogg a ride to the
Train
station and he was insisting the whole
time I don't worry and she's gonna meet
me here at the train station Sam and his
friends they're like she's not coming
I'm like no I said here's what we'll do
we'll wait at the train station with you
until she gets here I said okay and then
he was texting I'm on my way I'm on my
way until the phone call finally came in
that said now that you're at the train
station I want you to know I'm not what
happened it wasn't it wasn't a phone
call I I called right yes she didn't
pick up I did no you didn't yes I didn't
pick up and then you texted me I'm not
gonna make it okay because I thought I
was going to I thought I was going to
why didn't you make it because I was
having fun you can invite hot talk back
for further fun why didn't you invite
him back you also did say I'm on my way
I'm leaving now I'm calling an uber okay
you did say that was that a fabrication
maybe okay why why did you say your
corner in September y'all and you're
still talking about maybe I was wrong
I'm a good friend - you are a good
friend yeah I brought this up since they
know I know it that it just fascinates
me that y'all are so fascinated by that
because you didn't you were gonna go you
were gonna go back with him why did you
invite him back to have fun with the bar
because I went home with someone is that
what we want I don't know I don't know
did you good thank you
was it the guy from the dating game no
it was no okay were you jealous I was
mad that wasn't hot dog when he was
crushed you know I was very angry angry
not like who it was or but because I
just ditched you in general just the
principal - yeah it's not because of
what you're doing I was losing as man if
it was Travis no though Travis and I
aren't as close as that you and Travis
are gonna ride the train and Travis is
like hey I'm gonna stand here and [ __ ]
somebody would you be angry that's how
guys talk that's it blogger would you
have been mad if he said I'm gonna stay
out here and hang out with this girl I
would have been like
bad you wouldn't ever you were so petty
after that those n until you met him
telling me how you felt you really oh
I'm gonna send her short text and just
not talk to her which talk to me openly
cuz we are friends and that's what
friends do he's sending you short text
and not getting the five I was
distracted okay bye why will we distract
away anyways no and so if you just told
me hey that wasn't cool I'm upset I make
great looks like I'm sorry let's talk
about this but I don't regret my
decision to do that not my lane to be
mad at me I was just like I just don't
want to talk to you for that whole week
okay you last like three days it was
like Saturday here's the thing but he
couldn't do it more than a week more
than three days he couldn't go without
talking here well I mean because he's
not gonna just like no I would never
ignore a friend just for a week here's
the thing Jim in my opinion sometimes
with relationships I don't even know
what this is
but in my experience with relationships
sometimes if you're like in love with
somebody and they ditched you to hang
out with somebody else and do whatever
you'll be way more mad at them than you
would just read a guy and then you'll be
like I'm not talking to you for a week
but for the same reason you're in love
with them no you can't stop talking know
it because that's the things like I
think hot dog would have been less mad
if I was just up front if I was like hey
I'm just not gonna make it at all he big
all right well he said now I know we
both agreed all right we're gonna lead
together at this time because you want
to get home early and I need to do
something I need to meet up with someone
at a certain time you still went out
that night you're gonna do your sit at
home and cry wait you went out with
someone that night too yeah and that's
why I was mad I was like we need to
begin to train at this time are you
still seeing them no Oh shocker so I
know but you also got to go to the
wedding with hot dog and you could
yes well we're talking about handsome
Rob's wedding she was you ended right it
right when was that wedding oh yes so
the month before this is actually a
month before and so I came in here to be
the villain no no we're trying to get
things straight
how does date you're supposed to be hot
dogs date and then I believe if I
remember right if I you may correct me
week of you were canceled on week of I
she told me for a while that she didn't
know it was maybe me I love definitely
no definitely definitely I got the
definite no why did you only give them
maybe because I wasn't sure because of
one dudes you weren't sure what know
what okay so that weekend I ended up not
going because I had to go work out in
the Hamptons
all right yeah I was babysitting so I
was working I needed the money
right yeah I was just like oh she needs
to make some money so but before that
why weren't you sure cuz you didn't know
you're gonna babysit until week up so
before that you're like I wasn't what
weren't you sure of well cuz I was like
what does something better comes along
like babysitting oh wow nor dick no no I
put a guide to date or a friend a
friendship thing did you not want to
commit to going on being his date who
something better might come along well
well just because we're it was in
Philadelphia yeah yeah and I didn't cuz
now I feel it now as I'm insulting rob
and hotdogs sorry whatever this is true
but I heard it was a great wonderful
wedding fun and I just don't really like
weddings and plus the Hamptons is
further than Philly a lot of money that
weekend but it wasn't about the money
cuz you were telling him before you
didn't know if you're gonna go well
because I don't want to commit that far
ahead
smart who wants to commit to a wedding
is it's what you do your feelings were
hurt when she didn't go oh you had a
better time with your friend
and with me with these I can run a date
and her boyfriend why would he have had
a better time with a date and her
boyfriend yeah then we'd had a good time
it was it was dope though we were she
danced with Mary Jean I was dancing
everyone's wives so cool nothing better
than being the non-threatening so I you
know you aren't sure if you want the
commit cuz you didn't know if you would
enjoy the wedding
it wasn't about that the companionship
at the wedding you didn't know it could
be better companionship just the wedding
never I never went I babysat instead
right everything's fine
are you afraid of sending the wrong
signals this is what women do too I have
to like they're afraid that all if I go
on these things he's gonna think that I
like him like that
and I have to be very careful not to
send that say no cuz he's my friend I've
done that before with other guys but
with hot dog we've never Vito's date was
also the same what do you mean Vito's
date for the wedding ones but we're not
here to play my friend we're here to
talk about Vito and the girl that Vito
was with but it was it was more like it
was like a FOMO thing with both of them
where they were like well if we find
something cooler or something more funny
video you know and his date weren't like
best friends that also you know you know
was in love with I'm friends with her
and we were both like doing really want
to go and guy I hate talking about this
like feel like I'm insulting robbed me
upset Rob's fine yeah also Hamptons is
20 minutes further they yeah they did
this further 20 minutes in traffic you
want a minute yeah bad traffic at the
him in August
oof yeah terrible forget about it
trouble so um so you need Robert doesn't
care
no yeah I mean and I don't ever worry
about sending hot dog the wrong signal I
didn't care I was like I figured she
Polly wasn't gonna come and then I like
I called Annie yeah and she was like
yeah yeah come she drove us and can I
bring my boyfriend she said I'll say
yeah [ __ ] yeah how did this how did your
friendship
start well I was actually in this studio
and he was like hiding behind a door and
someone was like oh that's the I don't
know it did it introduce us hot dog or
che
I can't yeah the mysterious hot dog I
don't know and then we started working
together on one of the shows and then we
just became friends how
- did you realize that hotdogs had
feelings for you not necessarily love
but just feel healthy friends for a long
time now and I still haven't felt that
so I can't tell you Jim do you believe
that no I mean you really a nope I'm not
even fine we're best friends that's so
cool I'm saying I'm not even saying
right now fine I'll give you right now
to at no point were you like I mean I'm
not even I'm not even questioning your
feelings but at no point did you look at
hotdogs and go like you know he's not
really treating anybody else with this
kind of attack first of all yes he does
who yes he does one of his other friends
who's a girl best friends where we never
hear about never never hear anything
because y'all know me more so why it's
gonna bring up random anyways or
interesting okay I know but she doesn't
still see y'all as much as I do but how
long into did you realize he had a
different feeling women can always say
never so when when everybody around hot
date other girls - how's that gone great
really it's easy man
I can't look stupid I can't fix your
stupid with girls I can do this why
didn't you still be with girls like what
do they do wrong with you Angie do you
think for a second that maybe he's like
one of the reasons why you're not that
good hook him up with other girls is
because that's not really in his heart
what do you want yeah hooking me up with
other girls
you're the 108 it's like Ozzie getting
me tickets for another band I don't know
I keep getting tickets never shows up to
these concerts oh I'll go on a date and
if it goes well or bad I'll talk to her
about it and usually probably ends up
bad and then or it was good and then
you're do something hotdogs like then
like that where so something that
hotdogs will do he'll say something that
sounds like so much of an insult but he
just thinks it's normal it's called
nagging it works and rankings
Nega no but that's just him he's that
lot of game thing of us
specific example are just like oblivious
you're talking to this one girl you
can't talk to her about another girl
well obviously he doesn't know that if
he's talking to you about all of his
dates no he's trying to show her that he
has another option of course you but
they keep failing and you know why will
in st. Louis has a point let's go to
well what's that buddy you know I don't
I don't want a woman shame and you know
75% but yeah Angira cold ass honkey oh
did you consider yourself a cold ass
honkey feel cold well I've never heard
that term before cold ass honkey mm-hmm
ladies one thing holdouts honkies a
whole other thing do you think you're
cold or no no no we're best friends we
call each other just like talk or hang
out oh man a girlfriend I had lots of
best friends you have to call me a
girlfriend weird do you hate that she
sees you like that no you sleep in bed
with intern Annie those friends just
friends
yeah little twin size bed he'll sleep in
bed with her and Mitch's friends too and
she like a million times
yeah and her boyfriend is just like yeah
she's sleeping with hot dog right now I
mean nothing doesn't yeah of another I
mean because her boyfriend was hot dogs
best friend right and there's no best
friends soon he gets it
dogs not a threat not a right way shape
or form
he's just a normal good person all right
hot dog yes you your friend Annie that
we keep mentioning your former intern
shaman right other best friend and Angie
mm-hmm do you really think they're
members of the same category yeah yeah
hot dog yes then why are you smiling
when you say I would say your flash this
time I would say you're blushing but
can't tell you think you think andis
attractive Oh weirdness yeah I mr. mayor
what do you what do you think is
attractive
we're shooting this why I'm not doing IQ
dude my girlfriend from years ago is my
closest friend we don't [ __ ] me on to I
can easily talk what do you think is
attractive about your friend your ex
who's your friend Jen she's a beautiful
face she's a pretty lip she's great
smile
she's great body I'm phenomenal ass like
so it it's alright she's my friend now
we don't talk up at all they ever hooked
up in many years talking I don't do that
so what do you think woody trash you
said she's attracted you did say them
yeah what do you think oh not like you
don't have to don't I brother you answer
me the same thing that's like what go
ahead see three no no no no she knows
she's picking up yeah that's fine I'm
gonna do that thing Hamid only thing
what's the thing
so are you like you've read in the face
just start spazzing out I do I start
stabbing
why are you uncomfortable yes I mean
answer you did ask to come on this is
your fault
what do you mean embarrassment what
knives you were just against the bottom
of your dynamics both of you guys know
you don't anything wrong
Jim and I are the truth Sayers yeah
that's all we want to get to the bottom
of is the truth oh that's what it is
yeah what do you think this is a
repossession what do you think he's
attractive about it we're not doing this
that's fair no it's not the exact when I
smile yeah right pretty smile yeah what
else let me ask you do you think Angie
is prettier on the outside of the inside
the inside yeah you know I I was only
saying that just now because sometimes
she is very mean but is she mean
sometimes what does she do this mean hot
dog like ambushed me in studio what does
that mean like this right now this is a
mean thing to do this is a mean thing to
do well I was trying to find you I
thought you were here and then I asked
you just magically show up here cuz I
went all around this I went on 36 well I
mean I did text me last week too and
we're like hey we're both here you want
to do know that's true but today it was
but and then all the yeah hot dogs in
Lobby there let's go get it mother okay
I did also text you right before I came
in here and I said just go home Sam
wants me in studio no I don't want you
to go home because we were gonna leave
together and take the train actually
gonna take the train with him this time
Sam's Sam wants me to come inside go on
without me I think I can carry on
without you but instead you showed up
here right so what does she mean I don't
know what you think is mean yeah I don't
know sometimes she just says weird [ __ ]
like you say or sometimes just like the
Long Island thing or but what she says
yeah I'm not I never like verbally abuse
you in a hole yesterday you uh we were
talking about the date yeah I told her
that she deserves better than you yes I
didn't make that his date that no I told
him that what you why would you wanna
sabotage has eight months I it's
exhausting hearing about this and you
are just setting yourself up for failure
with her and she seems so sweet she's
nice she's amazing I know and why does
she why does she deserve better than hot
dog well just cuz of the way he's
handling this he's like well she didn't
text me back for three hours so I wait
six hours to text her back just petty
stuff that's a normal relationship the
things that she's heard that you've done
with other I'm gonna stops I don't open
for him he's fine no I know but I really
oh yeah I am worried that after this hot
dog is gonna be upset what's done is
done
yeah we're just talking we're not what
did he say in the error makes a good
point that somehow I'll bet within 48
hours no matter how man he gets hot I
will find it in his heart to forgive you
mmm-hmm so woody why did you say that
she deserved better than hot dog
was it the threesomes the Devils
triangles the drinking games you know he
had a threesome with another guy
did you I don't if you know he's a
larger penis and people thought he did
he's a big dick does that gross stop it
really I'm like I'm sweating what were
you gonna say why why did you want to
sabotage his no I'm not sabotaging it's
because for eight months I have been
telling him like this is a nice girl if
you're gonna hang out with her stop
leading her on if you're not gonna he's
like no and then he kinda like stops
talking to her and then she hears about
him doing someone else and then she her
facing someone else like half a year a
year having sex with other people
and she's hearing about it that someone
squealed and yes and he saw her face and
she's like look devastated and then you
know I started to hang out and again I
don't know it's weird that hot dog would
find somebody that is like obviously so
into him and he just doesn't care about
absolutely and he would actually have
sex and let her find out about I mean
it's got to be horrible to do to a
friend such a long stretch and not got a
boner and it was the whole thing that's
you know that's true I think it was that
one check I can't get epona way it
happens yeah so it bothers you to hear
they use the bigger penis so what it's a
good thing he's got a real mule Troy saw
it on a video why did you say it's gross
no woman thinks a big penis is gross you
know no I just don't think it's like
thinking about I just know I think you
you wouldn't think about your brother
like that I'm not getting about a hot
dog like that no I don't know your
brother though yeah my brother smoking a
bunch too good for you guys for you guys
yeah cuz that's at socks not your hot
dog do you look at Angie like a sister
know that I don't look at her as a close
friend won't look at anyone it's a wait
how do we go from best friends to close
friends well cuz you're not my best
friend best friend you're what but we've
just read we had like a discussion about
this you're like yeah you're one of my
best friends yeah
I'm not gonna be like I'm not gonna be
like one of your brows or anything well
you're not my best friend but you're one
of my best friends you're a close friend
yeah but you were saying he was your
best friend he's one of my best friends
right the same thing yeah okay
it feels longest feels like the
friendship is a little more heavy on the
engine I agree but you you when you
mention his penis shoes oh my god it's
gross but do you think the thinking of
her naked is gross no no that's that's
immature Zach gross right no and that's
it's like you know six year old woman oh
yeah like if you were like everybody you
don't want to think of me I doing things
with other guys like you'd rather not
hear about that I've heard from you
about that in detail you don't need all
those details that much detail I bother
you no I've never told you things in
that much detail what didn't you tell
there's more detail boy what didn't you
tell him do you like the details or you
don't like the details I know I just
listen to the details I'm not like going
like oh that's [ __ ] gross right she
was into anal sex or no she's not she
just said all the butt stuff she's
probably telling us you're joking no
she's not no okay I Travis in Kentucky
would like to make a comparison I
believe what's up Travis hey I know you
guys already her and I've got plenty I
could throw on that but I'm curious to
know I had a friend just like that and
how do you how do you say friends dog
that makes no sense I mean there's no
way you had that strong eye feelings but
if you did I know there's no way I could
stay friends because that's just up in
there and I couldn't do it say friends
like despite what I think any in love
with her and attracted to her yeah I
think you're you objecting to the fact
that you're in love with her most of the
audience has put that on the complete
pain oh my yeah we don't believe you
know we don't because honestly like it
wouldn't make I mean it wouldn't make
sense like it's too much to deal with in
a friendship it doesn't like why would
you our friendship isn't isn't crazy we
we hang out at work all the time and
then and then
no I think we hang out at work every
time we vote come over to each other's
places and like chill we'll just hang
out and like hang out with our other
friends too that's fine there's nothing
there's nothing crazy about it we've
been to your house together I do my
mandatory look you ever sit on the couch
alone and watch a movie I can't sit
still for that long so no attention span
oh yeah I do they did go to my house
together that short yeah we did yeah
and they were next to each other the
whole time having a great time together
mm-hmm
I was putting your dog mainly but sure
you'd like the dog more than hot dog not
we were I think like me and you and like
Joe we're just talking about things and
Angie it was just like neurone little
men were talking all abroad pet the
animals that makes sense yeah I get that
so when when when other people not just
us or people outside the show go like
will clearly hot dogs in love with you
never never they may not see it as much
as we hear all the detail okay well when
everybody here goes like well yeah
clearly that's what's happening do you
go that is crazy like I don't even
understand what they're seeing because
that's a whole other world I really
don't understand it's weird
who do you think values your time
together more you or him of the two of
you who do you think is more likely to
break plans well who do you think values
your time together more I would say me
no no seriously because whenever we have
a really fun night I'm always the one to
like call him or attacks in big there
was so much fun right and if he's like
huh yeah I'm like what you didn't have a
great time or like last yeah when you
really want to do something after this
and I was like yeah maybe and then you
got upset yeah how many time night did
shoot a wedding train station yeah are
you talking about me I'm a high
maintenance person and he just he puts
up with the COS he's just know it's
interesting I never had a high
maintenance friend become either why
would I deal with a high member forever
sometimes if I was out with Bob Kelly
and he wanted to stay if he was single I
wanted to do something it wouldn't
bother me at all
yeah I could kick Bob suit if Bob Kelly
checked into a hospital
still go home and not care yeah bye see
ya it's also like it's not like we don't
go out of our ways to see each other
that's just like Andrew but can I come
over like using computers in the data
yeah and then I'm just like if you're
able to meet for dinner he's like yeah I
can meet for dinner but after sandwich
thing honey you don't have to go out of
your way to see each other if you see
each other six times a week we don't see
each other that often though you just
said you hang out at work every day we
are at work why do you have to use this
computer you know one no I do have one
but what do you like but about his it's
no it's just a different it's just
different it's a PC and it's something
that's easier for me to navigate that
one and oh we have fun hanging out in
Harlem I see yeah and this is a this
started when I was using that tablet
thing remember yeah so we were editing
videos in my tablet so she had a
computer at her place and she would go
hey hot dog I'm gonna leave my computer
behind can I come over and borrow your
tablet yeah sometime see my mom like in
a towel oh my gosh his mom but you would
never go like why would anybody decide
to forgo using a computer for video work
and choose tablet he was teaching me how
to do idea I've never done it before and
so he was I see yeah it's very he's
useful but that's very very are you a
little kid a little bit you just
described your best friend as useful did
I not just say yes I'm cold
I'm high-maintenance I'm not I wouldn't
be friends with me so that's why I do
value the friendships I have but people
do you ever wonder why would anybody put
up with this yes I could never be
friends with me
I haven't yes so that's why so that's
why I always appreciate hot dog all my
friends love you we have so much fun
yeah what is it about how come you don't
look at him like he could be possibly
more than a phrase a good-looking guy
he's a nice guy
yeah actually you know what we asked hot
dog are you attracted at all physically
too and yeah we did ask him he admitted
that you're very beautiful you had a
great ass he said I didn't say that yes
you said Jen had a great ass and you
said all the things about Jen I feel
about he was like I guess like shoulder
shrug you don't think
she's a nice heinie no we're not talking
about my no no no no no you guys are
best friends yeah how is that so bad
don't go up like my to my other best
friends but you know what I love you but
you know what Troy's a choice he's my
bro and he talks to me about fat asses
all the time is never is fine hotdogs
like it Jimmy's got a great ass
thank you yeah appreciate that yeah I
haven't noticed I've been told
yeah it's really nice thank you okay but
if we are I don't know justify it no
because if we're out like we see a
good-looking person we'll play all of it
that's a handsome dude or like oh that
doesn't match it you say that outside
like oh I got that dude over there no oh
yeah yeah if she's oh all the time like
other girls that he's I kind of ride
with like likes from afar he's like
she's so pretty and he'll tell me that
day do you think hotdog attractive as a
yes no I talk about as a human being as
physically that's it
man I saw a lot of gums in that smile
that's the biggest smile I've ever seen
from him no but do you think he's
attractive as a man not just as your
friend he's a good-looking guy
if you tell G you didn't know him you're
not friends you just see him like oh
that's a good-looking guy or and that
for me just personal taste no circus
after this no matter what I say you're
me whatever you know he thinks that
you're good-looking that's not that do
you think Angie is beautiful I've told
you that before that's not what can I
pour you into it oh hey look fine and
you're like uh-huh I'm like white and
you're yeah you look great
okay great so what now which is by the
way what you do with your friends Jim I
meant to tell you this morning when you
walked in you look beautiful even have a
butt Sam always picks me up Sam tells
you but a lump of [ __ ] I look like every
day I have to lose two pounds he looks
it his gut every single time I go yeah
yeah or maybe more maybe more oh yeah I
see that yeah first of all you should
even be worried about
that uh I would worry a little sure your
vine vine listen oh that's right you're
great I hate saying fine now that you
know that hot dog thinks that you're an
interactive beautiful girl okay what is
physically if you weren't friends with
hot dog yeah
would you be like that's a good-looking
guy or not my type yes like that's a
good-looking guy but not my type like
there's it eight that's it
I'm not your tight yep what not you're
tweeting you're blond and gorgeous look
great funny this type aren't you don't
my job what you say Angie is not your
type I have a specific type that I like
the most but I don't not have a type
gotcha so you say she's your type like
my favorite type is like a like an Asian
girl or something like but no but you're
like you're talking like types like a
guy wouldn't be attracted to if you're
not your type you know what guys types
are anything yeah anyone good-looking
girls right go to gym and sack okay
please what's going on Jim Angie's full
of [ __ ] she knows that hot dogs got a
thing for her
I think you're full of [ __ ] you play
with this poor guys emotion that make
you happy no one you can get away with
whatever you want no sir
yeah never if he has ever he's never
confessed any sort of feelings towards
me I'm sorry have you ever never even
hinted have you ever even actor ever in
the relationship have you ever even in
the beginning when you first meet Angie
mm-hmm Oh in the beginning I think
anyone's did you have feelings for her
in the beginning no that's an attractive
like she's hot but you didn't crush on
her in the beginning no well cause it
I'm Han hot we can't get anywhere she
wants to come in here she was to come in
here dad wants to talk about anything
she won't admit that she's dangling the
carrot in front of his face right in
front of his carrot yeah exactly
Oh
he's just no string right along
vegetables I have had guy friends I have
a guy friends who I have known have
liked me a certain way and I didn't like
them that way and what do you do leave
them at the train station depends on
who's at the bar right what what have
you done in the past have you roped them
along a little bit because it's fun it's
not no if they bring it up or it's a
source mentioned then it's like I don't
feel the same way like I'm comfortable
with being friends but if you're not
that's ok and or I've liked a guy and he
hasn't liked me back and then hopefully
I would hope that he would do like the
same thing usually they just you know do
the slow fade and ghost but Lonnie is
picking up on something here Lonnie
North Carolina mhm yeah there's a just
slap it on the table
Thank You Lonnie is right
I mean there normally is a certain
degree of sexual tension between Jim and
myself and Troy like the charm three-way
sexual tension between friends yeah but
there is a degree of unsaid miss in your
attention and I don't feel that me Jim
do you feel it from him to her yeah not
from her to him no mmm right no we've
all everyone has been in this situation
a bunch I've been sewing yes so I'm not
[ __ ] on you I completely get it
that's how we know we're talking about
cuz I've been there many times but I
like someone they don't like me but
women again they're more company I can
be friends with you but I like they
don't want to acknowledge the elephant
in the room because then they have to
make a decision on the friendship during
hot dogs dick yeah yeah I mean you'll
get to you get yourself to a point where
you'll go you know what you know you
have these feelings I've been there this
is how I have felt before
or I'll go I'll convince myself that
it's better if I have this person's
attention on like this much of it at
least it's better to be friends than to
not have that attention at all and
that's all well and good until train
station gate happens and you go this
reins this is the
difference because I'm this is what it
is I'm friends with a lot of women who I
don't sleep with good friends that
doesn't surprise me
yeah which is Fran that's very that's a
very shitty thing actually a fine
compliment that's not I'm taking as a
fine couple of meaning Wow Jim's a good
guy no he's saying I don't blame them
for not [ __ ] you just a different
interpretation the same effect but I
don't get grossed out if I think about
them naked like I got thinking about
women I've worked with and yeah I
picture her nakedness it's just maybe
going also maybe it's my upbringing is
different I'm is it because he's not
white it's a great question why that
could be it
and it is taught in the home is that
true mm-hmm I'm yes I am from Texas no
I'm not a race issue if you brought hot
dog home for any reason no not at all
okay no I mean my mom cuz never if I met
him but she knows about hot dog and you
talked to your mom about hot dog yeah
he's one of my best friends oh I talked
to my mom about everything that was
another thing you did remember when you
had her call and asked if I can cover
one of your shifts and put me on spot
that wasn't his mom she did I cover for
you
that same week as I was pissed off and I
I was like you made me say yes to your
mom that's true what were you pissed off
about what happened well I was in
Connecticut because my I was then I was
there and I'll be there there's a home
there Connecticut my parents have a
house there oh yes no I wasn't there
getting dick and somebody's got a guilty
conscience she goes to [ __ ] bridge
for whatever is in the past and I
covered for you that week anyway why did
you have to cover for him you're in
Connecticut you're on the phone your mom
is there you've got to manipulate me a
little bit I see yeah it's true I did
have my mom on speakerphone I was like
Maha's hotdogs for me because then he
can't say no ask what if he could just
cover his shifts for me so I could stay
some more time with my mother who I
don't see because she's usually
Austin oh you made your mom call guilt
hot dog into taking over your shift no I
have a busy schedule so did you not
think to yourself I can get hot dog to
take over this shift obviously you
thought that but the reason being is
that there are certain feelings here
he's going to say yes sure I I go out of
my way for friends like just friends and
so does hot dog
if Angie's asked me directly I would
have said no I know you said you're
Angie you owe me it was like yeah I do
and I stuck to that I did I wasn't like
I'm not gonna do that hot dog that's an
example of sometimes when you do things
that you know a little bit manipulative
yeah it's worth it no no because I want
to be friends with her if she wasn't but
there are like you mind me she's like
that what I want it's worth it I mean is
that what I want it's worth it that's
literally your quote that you just said
we could pull it up if you want we have
the technology
no it's true I mean yeah right but I
still did what you asked me I just
brought that up so the only the only
issue of concern is that and this is you
know as Jim and I have said we've both
been in situations and we've observed
other people in situations maybe this
isn't one of those situations where
there is a friendzone thing happening
and what tends to happen is the guy will
allow himself to be taken advantage of
and the girl will say well look if this
is going to be right here I'm gonna take
advantage being on it and you're like if
I had money in the bank account what am
I going to sit there and be like oh I
can't go out to dinner tonight like
there's money in the bank account
offended but they're not my sky who I
can just you know kick the [ __ ] out of
no punch in the face
you know rub is rub his nose and [ __ ]
whatever I want to do and why not do
that how I rubbed your nose and [ __ ]
exactly I picked up on that thanks guys
friend-zoned
isn't foreign to me I've been
friend-zoned before this isn't like and
like I've never heard of that did it
bother you when she did it no no there
is never a friend zone oh we always just
maintain friends right now - this is not
that yeah
hot dog yeah if Angie came to you uh-huh
oh don't do and she goes like hot light
this is weird I know we've been friends
for a long time yeah but what have we
just let's go out to dinner okay and
maybe just see if it's anything let's
actually go on a date let's go on a date
let's go to dinner
obviously we're gonna go to the Comedy
Cellar because it's a date yeah go - for
everybody but she said let's go out to
dinner let's go on a date would you go
like what would you do do not know I
would I would laugh and then I okay
about it
but you would but I wouldn't take it
seriously there's a man but you would do
it you would try if you knew that it
wouldn't be sex but you might hold hands
and you just go that's it's just gonna
see you're gonna go and see what the
chemistry's like on a date yeah weird
weird but tell me if she said let's just
see what this feels like I'm not asking
you to ask her I'm saying she's asking
you what ifs are so stupid hypotheticals
on the radio no but because even just
describing like the holding hands thing
deal we're not talking about a date she
says let's see let's go on Lincoln let's
go on one of your dates you don't think
when you put the image out there it's
weird to are just completely out of
their [ __ ] money
well you don't believe you hotdogs
hotdogs if she came up to you and said
we should go on a date even if you were
kind of you might laugh because it's
like awkward and it's been so long and
everything right you'd say yes of course
you would what else are you doing you're
trying to say face no hot dog no I'm
sure not the alpha male all right we're
just not compatible though why not he's
a penis phrasing it's quite a big penis
yeah
thank you yeah he's he's holding hot
doggers Holden Holden but I've been in
situation where I'm crushing on this
girl really hard and I might it might be
the case right now with you-know-who
yeah I did yeah I'm sure but like I'll
crush on a girl he hardens happening my
ex too and I'll I'll keep like being
persistent and bothering them yeah hey
let me take it really doesn't bother
she'll tell me they'll tell me no and
okay let me take you on a date now when
I asked you why would that situation I
asked you a van GSU I know this is
different yeah you're in love with this
woman this is different you wanna know I
was in love with my ex and that's
exactly how I read you wouldn't fire
shrimp if we really think about it's
always me who asked to hang out yeah
yeah it's always my idea so she said to
you I wanna go on let's just go on a
date and try it I already admitted you
would say yes I think I I think you
would be like are you okay no no what do
you think he'd say if you said for real
if you said not let's fog less I hold
hey let's go on a date and see what
happens in honesty what do you think he
would say I don't know about that what
would be the difference from us going
out to dinner or what you know Mantic
possibilities like you know right now
that there's not much of a romantic
possibilities later just using the word
date doesn't magically change that yes
you're exactly I mean we've hung out the
ones you want to do this doesn't change
a thing it doesn't change anything
why don't you go on a date because
that's just like hanging out for us okay
yeah but then why don't you just go on a
date if it doesn't change anything don't
you think that if she said mm-hmm
date let's see what happens right barely
changed the dynamic you're going with
new intention oh my thought would be
we've already been on we've hung out for
the last year and a half what is almost
things that have been almost like date
like how it's not other people where'd
you Patrick said to you let's go on a
date what would you say no exactly you
wouldn't have to do so I'm not sitting
here going through all this rigmarole no
I'm trying to explain it off Angie can I
tell you something I believe you yeah I
think you're being honest so you guys
don't hug at all you know what we need I
did on your birthday you know what we
need
[Music]
I got my birthday card I ran around got
P is very nice cards you know what we
need a lie detector yeah we need a lie
detector in here that's it
I believe you Angie we need to get it we
need to get a lie detector in here and
we need to get to the bottom of of
what's going on all right I mean because
I feel like we have made no movement
whatsoever absolutely there was a cousin
I've always stood by this this well
you're not admitting to what how do we
you know hot dog that's going to your
attention believe it
you do you do you don't want to miss
being as dishonest as anyone has ever
been in the student I would not have
come in the studio if I actually thought
he had feelings like that for me because
I would have put him through that yes
you were telling your whole exercise was
to humiliate hot dog yeah mostly crush
him come on you're dangling the carrier
not stupid you're a bright girl you know
what you're doing she is smart look I'm
a big fan of Angie Mito sure I think
she's great me too I think you're fun I
think you're smart I think you're great
oh but I don't have any problems tell
you that either Mickey Mouse all of a
sudden no he doesn't you know what
happens what when guys are nervous about
their truths coming out sometimes their
voice goes up several yeah exactly does
it all the time with you you know when
he doesn't do it when he's hanging out
with me yeah his voice remains constant
well you need to sure I've never heard
that voice noise also does that too when
he just he speaks normal when we're just
talking Oh or exasperated yeah there's
many times that hot dogs like I don't
want to hang out and like he doesn't
follow through on hanging out sure he's
a flake that does mean he's not in love
with you
yeah well yeah I mean both can be the
case but if there was the case of her
stringing me along I would be a [ __ ]
lap dog and it's been three years three
years it's ready it's been a year and a
half at least you're getting strung
along so let me ask you the idea of
giving Angie a kiss that bothers you
yeah yeah that's weird
who do you believe right now it's weird
whoa I believe her it's weird for me
personally I want I know and I watch
both their faces
I believe Angie is telling the truth and
a hot dog is being very dishonest you
don't think he thinks it's weird tell me
that I asked me if I think kissing a
girl would be fun do you think kissing a
girl would be fun did you believe me
just now did you I didn't believe you
thank you Jim so if hot dog had a date
last weekend and he called me out
regards oh good because I'm pretty sure
you got one more failure before we have
to go on a date with my brother but
that's besides yes so how was it it was
it was great
it's just it's been a while since we
this isn't like the first date I've gone
out with her and I'm kind of messed up
beforehand so it's kind of just like
yeah so just how did you mess up kept
something edgy no she did ask about me
on the date though she's like how's
Angie you knows about me yeah and
hotdogs went on for 30 minutes funny you
know she was wearing the striped shirt
at work today and I saw her wear the
striped shirt earlier and she sometimes
wears it on on Mondays but this was a
Tuesday and so I didn't know whose yeah
shell sauce about Annie it wasn't just
me and if she was telling me about you
like oh she's so pretty it was so fun I
hope she wants to go out with me again
you know I'm trying I went over she's
very nice I know but you messed up
pretty bad in the past that's what I
said I'm trying to win her all right you
can't be petty and text her back six
hours later because she waited three
hours that's ridiculous
this female friend that hotdog has a
knee that we keep bringing over like
we've all seen them together yeah they
have complete friendship chemistry
towards no romantic chemistry at all
between them and it's equal and they're
both and it's a great friendship he's
not sheepish or shy no but both hotdog
and Angie are using Annie as an excuse
to be like what's your daddy it is it
isn't like no it's not no we do things
right
Greece's robbed this way is there no one
in this room who agrees rating do you
think we're making something out of
nothing
oh you don't know yeah no one Travis
Travis do you don't think he's in love
with idea what do you don't think he's
in love with her dear in that carriage
you say I'm not stupid but I also do
know what it's like to have a guy friend
who likes you right but you know what
happens in friend zone friend zone
scenario hit and friend zone scenarios
the minute one party puts on the table
what's actually going on the whole
business is destroyed all of a sudden
it's you can no longer pretend that you
can no longer go on to the illusion that
it doesn't exist once it's addressed
I've been there before and i i I'm not
the type to be like okay like I
literally go like no I'll just let me
take you out on one date and let's see
what happens like I've been there more
than one occasion yeah except for when
you're told you yes like there I'd there
would have been necessarily true Angie
there's different ways men feel
sometimes you meet a girl and you're
like oh she's cool yeah I want to go on
a date with her something and then
there's another version of that when you
meet a girl and you're like oh my god
like I think I just want to spend the
rest of my life with you saying
sometimes it's more love than lust yeah
yeah the last girl from December the one
from the Bronx that right I kept asking
out I'm sure yeah kept saying no no no
no you thought girl was cute you wanted
a dater that's not what we're saying is
going on yeah that's different from
being in love I had feeling like I was
talking ing about her all the time I
hear all about this yeah exactly because
you're not willing to risk them no like
you know that she will say no at this
point hurt knows is what I'm trying to
say but right before her would mean more
oh my god it was uh no the final no
where you can no longer hope that she
changes her mind exact in there it's
many times because it disrupts the
relationship disrupt and then we're
living in this kind of fake world yeah
that were maintained like you know it
can be whatever
there's that the endorphin drip that you
always talk about ATS you get that in
relationships too and you can get a
little bit of that as long as this
friendship quote-unquote isn't disrupted
that's why when she doesn't go out on
the train or didn't crush a no-no but
that's why it's so crunchy years from
now this will still be talked about
that's stupid you know train yeah you
know why it'll be still talked about why
because it wasn't just a friend it was a
girl that he was in love with yeah if I
ever have kids he'll be uncle hot dog I
wanna be uncle hot dog no he doesn't
want to be uncle hot dog be dead he
wants to see I draw a line he was young
he wants to leave it in and whisper I
love you at the final yeah wants to say
he wants to say bite down the womb
Buster's true-or-false do you think
impregnation like women don't everything
it's gross to be knocked up women love
the edges exactly even if you're not
into it now he's thought gross to you as
a woman speaking of knocked up we have
to take a break yes Judd Apatow is here
is he here yet he's on his way up
oh thanks I wanna take a break but what
we need to do is we're not done with
this because neither one of you were
entirely forthcoming Ange you were a
little more forthcoming but neither one
of you were entirely we have to and
Travis we'll work on it we're gonna get
a lie detector in here and we're hooking
both of you up to it and we're gonna get
some questions answered I'm gonna pass
you won't well what I believe that's
true